en ce moment au québec il ya des
intérêts très très puissant qui veulent
transformer notre pays un autoroute pour
l'exportation des sables bitumineux
albertains
il ya des intérêts très puissant appuyés
par l'état canadien
appuyé par le gouvernement fédéral qui
nous prend qui veulent en ce moment nous
imposer un projet en particulier le
projet énergie s de transcanada un
projet d'oléoduc un mégot oléoduc 1 700
km de bar en bar du québec que vous
traversez notamment le fleuve
saint-laurent de plus grands joyau
national et on est en train de nous
imposer ce projet-là au mépris dans le
fond des gens qui vivent sur le
territoire du québec
le peuple québécois qui également aussi
les premières nations j'ai décidé de
donner le 25 mille dollars aux citoyens
et aux citoyennes qui en ce moment dans
leur région se mobilisent pour contrer
ce projet là une campagne qui s'appelle
culpa chez nous qui est organisé par six
comités citoyens tout le long du trajet
de l'énergie ça c'est des gens
ordinaires
les gens qui vont être touchés par un
éventuel déversement qui en ce moment
défendre nos intérêts collectifs comme
québécois en s'opposant à tout cas au
moins en réclamant un débat public sur
ce projet excessivement controversé moi
j'ai envie d'être solidaire avec ces
gens là j'ai envie d encourager il nous
défendent en ce moment il donc j'ai
décidé de leur remettre m